how's this arm coming along phase 2 on
the bionic arm bill we've got all of our
paint dry or already dried and now I'm
applying this into chase ran you're
ruining all my audio anyway I've got
industrial-strength velcro that I'm
using to secure the pieces of crafty
foam to the glove I can just do that put
it back on well that looks awesome
why are staples took home I painted them
and then I bought some crafty wire head
Michaels and I'm stringing those through
the glove to give it this knuckled
effect and then on the fingertips will
have these looking like that the source
of my power is now complete I finished
the arm got a little weathering
hopefully this will look pretty good
from not too close on camera supplies
used crafty foam crafty paint rivets
lacing outside of a plastic cup black
glove black sleeve velcro pretty good
for the limited amount of time I put
into it and we're ready to shoot the
video I got an interesting idea two
years back a neighborhood used to live
in our building did edgings in acrylic
he would light been with LED lights but
LED lights in the edge of acrylic the
etchings kind of glow so you know he had
a red panel a green panel and blue panel
and you layered them that effect that
gives you RGB pixels you can make any
color you want
hey Corey his name Corey after the
company Corey door so eventually I went
on Amazon I bought three pieces of
acrylic three sets of RGB LEDs with the
red LEDs on one set the green on another
and the blue one another and then I use
a dremel to go to town edging the whole
thing so here we have all the colors of
the rainbow by me touching on red blue
and green so let me show you if I split
this apart so you see here I've the blue
is kind of itched here the Reds come
edged here and the Greens kind of there
and so I put together it's a rainbow so
it's a kind of backup to get the full
effect here so I just did a little
landscape etching now the next step is
to go bigger I want to get a nice big
piece of acrylic like this
because any ideas thing that work with
this crazy color scheme let me know
crazy sunset with a laser bridge pink
tiger with green eyes an explosion with
laser beams there's lasers in it pretty
much guaranteed to work